de lo que voy a hablar en este vídeo en
las variables aleatorias
y éstas pueden ser un poco confusos al
principio porque seguro te van a
recordar a las variables tradicionales
que te enseñaron en la clase de álgebra
pero estas variables aleatorias no son
como ellas éstas son una forma de
asignarle un número a cosas como el
resultado de un experimento aleatorio
aunque entonces vamos a tener
experimentos aleatorios
vamos a tener un experimento aleatorio
por ejemplo pues está tirando una moneda
o unos dados o estás pensando en cuánta
lluvia va a caer mañana y al resultado
al resultado le puedes asignar un número
y bueno vemos un ejemplo de una variable
aleatoria que hoy vamos a definir la
variable aleatoria x mayúscula y
generalmente las variables aleatorias se
denotan con letras mayúsculas y bueno
vamos a definirla
como uno si tiramos un volado y no sale
ahí la ok
ayolas
y vamos a definirla como 0 si sale sol
esto lo pudo haber definido como yo
quisiera generalmente cuando estamos
hablando de volados se usan estos
números porque así es más sencillo pero
aquí puede haber puesto 100 si sale ahí
la y 703 y sale sol pero si lo piensan
es mucho más fácil pensar en que si sale
aquí la tenemos x igual a 1 y si sale
sol tenemos x igual a 0 a 100 y 703 no
pero bueno el chiste es que aquí ya
tenemos un experimento que es tirar una
moneda y aquí los resultados o sea si
sale de glaus al sol ya les estamos
asignando un número y a ver definamos
otra variable a ver ahora jay mayúscula
ok que les parece con la suma de 7 dados
dados aunque hoy a ver a qué me refiero
con la suma de siete dados en realidad
lo que yo quise decir es la suma de las
caras que caigan hacia arriba de siete
dados a ver si quieren lo escribo
entonces ya es igual a la suma de las
caras que caen hacia arriba de 7 dados
que tiramos y otra vez estamos
cuantificando el resultado de un
experimento aleatorio o sea tiramos los
7 dados y es el experimento aleatorio y
a partir de esos datos pues nos fijamos
en qué caras caen hacia arriba y sumamos
los números que están en esas caras y
así estamos definiendo la variable
aleatoria allí y bueno aquí la pregunta
más natural del mundo es para qué
estamos haciendo todo esto porque están
útiles o definir variables de esta forma
y pues eso va a quedar mucho más claro
cuando estemos metidos a fondo
estudiando probabilidad pero podemos
empezar por darnos cuenta que en cuanto
empezamos a cuantificar los resultados
ya podemos empezar a hacer cuentas con
ellos y además podemos usar notación
matemática lo cual generalmente hace que
las cosas sean mucho más sencillas y
claras por ejemplo si quisiera saber
cuál es la probabilidad de que la suma
de las caras que tienes de arriba de 7
dados sea menor o igual a 30
te tendrías que escribir la probabilidad
de que
la xoom
d
o sea aquí todo lo que escribimos aquí
menor o igual que 30
y si sustituye todo esto por acá pues es
un chorizo larguísimo no pero si usamos
esta anotación matemática nada más
necesitas escribir cuál es la
probabilidad de que ya sea menor o igual
que 30 mucho más sencillo y limpio no y
además por ejemplo si alguien más se le
ocurre preguntar bueno cuál es la
probabilidad de que la suma de las caras
que caen hacia arriba de 7 dados sea par
pues nada más tienes que escribir con la
probabilidad de que ya sea tarde
y listo
lo que sí quiero que quede muy claro es
que estas variables no son como las
variables de la clase de álgebra ok tal
vez en la clase de álgebra tienes
ecuaciones que dicen x 5 es igual a 6 o
es igual a x + 7 y pues por ejemplo al
menos en este caso
noten que generalmente en la clase de
álgebra las variables se notan con
letras minúsculas pero bueno en este
caso en la clase de álgebra seguro dice
fácilmente no sea pasó el 5 del otro
lado y ya me queda que x es igual a 1 o
sea estamos resolviendo la ecuación y
estamos encontrando que el valor de x
tiene que ser igual a 1 y en este caso
pues x puede tomar cualquier valor es
una variable y entonces pueden ver que
ya es una función de la variable x pero
con estas variables no vamos a poder
hacer ese tipo de cosas
ok las variables aleatorias toman
muchísimos valores y tiene mucho más
sentido hablar de la probabilidad de que
una variable aleatoria sea igual a un
número
o la probabilidad de que una variable
delator ya sea menor o igual que un
número o mayor o igual o la probabilidad
de que sea par o impar o el chiste es
que las probabilidades son lo que tienen
sentido con las variables aleatorias y
eso se puede ver muy claramente en estos
dos ejemplos en el próximo vídeo vamos a
seguir con esta discusión y vamos a ver
qué tipo de variables aleatorias te
puedes encontrar